Này chẳng cho biết chính quyền tổng thống Mỹ đơn nân trăm đã bắt đầu trình khai các bất đầu tiên trong kế hoàn xài thì bộ sáo sục Mỹ,
một chương nhiễm cảm kết, nhằm thua phải cho của chính phủ liên băng và chăng thiên quyền tự quyết cho các bạn trong lý mức sáo sục.
Theo kế hoàn bộ sáo sục sảy chuyển xa hoặc phối hấp tự kiện các trình năng với bối bối cơ quan, vô bộ lời động bộ ngoài xa của nội vụ và bối tế sỉnh vụ như sinh.
Để phối ẩm giữa bộ sáo sục và bộ lời động được kế vọng giúp sức lại các trình chính giáo sục tiêu học và chung học.
Đồng thời gian kế thể thống sáo sục, bởi như cầu đào tạo như lực.
Bộ nội vô sẽ tiếp khoản các trình chính giành trọng xin bản điểm Mỹ,
còn bộ ngoài xa hoàn chỉ chính giản các trình chính nguyễn và cháo đổi,
giành cho suốt xin, nhằm bao đam hiệu quả khóa li và phủ hợp bục tiêu ăn nguy cú xa.
Bây giờ thay bộ giáo sục Mỹ đánh giống khai đổi lớn, trong kế tức cận sáo sục của Washington.
Hướng tới mó hình sân quyền mạnh hơn và tập chú vận lực theo như cầu từ lĩnh vật.